mari ma cos'hai perché se così acido
amore fame dominare sono arrivate beh
allora c'è qualche problema ma me li
faccio e charlie sembra morta proprio
pari non ci sto male è vergine vari mass
ingrassata chiedo gonfia un ciclo e se
non ti puoi non far votare per favore
per esempio io non ci credo ma comune
accordo anzi sono più rilassata sembra
che non ce l'ho fantastico ma la cosa mi
stai ripara da un buon mar italiana
venga anche nel mar rosso moglie cusmai
da venaria almeno incinta
meglio così palla finisce qui mentre
stuffer se poi non ti lamentare che
viene quasi e brufoli
ma c'era mai tempo poi chissà che merda
ma ancora che mani sembra una pattumiera
più partito ma il mettere un punto
riteniamo e baby ma questa sera vieni
domani
sì certo vengo prove sappi che ogni cose
spero non sia un problema
no ai cicloni
vabbè dai allora facciamo un'altra volta
buona serata che pezzo di merda cosa fai
amore dai molla mi sembra che voglia di
farlo se per mi stai addosso di marcia
divertenti ma gli animali sono dei cazzi
tranquillo è ancora ci sei
e allora c'è qualche problema sarà due
settimane che c'è un problema mi avrete
cosa fa il motto bari ma di chi sono sì
ma con i miei perché c'è oggi
promettendo ai tumori aiutandomi la5
c'erano tutte le donne cioè come questo
che rende onore e dovete vedere nessuno
domani andiamo al mare da ma non ci
credo radici giorni che vi dico che
voglio andare al mare e poi quando e
cantate domani io c'ho le mie cose ma da
e proprio di amici merda beh ma
l'illusione precoce vieni lo stesso con
noi e non ti fa il bagno
certo ormai non vi faccio il bagno è
chiaro ma pensate da amore o non può
essere ancora letto il gioco io sto male
cosa che fai tu il circo di to sono
malissimo century domenica facciamo da
passeggiate facciamo girare la voglia
vaga giocata domani
guarda che ci cancellando tutte stato un
momento se leggeranno 90 gerando sto
ragionando non volerlo telaio vaghi no
no non puoi capire quando di stamane e
molto di destra
[Musica]